كان وزير خارجية لبنان
من 2014 حتى هذا العام بشكل أساسي
طوال الوقت الذي
تم فيه تخزين هذه المواد شديدة الانفجار في الميناء وهو حاليًا
عضو في البرلمان
اللبناني وصهر الرئيس ميشال عون
البرازيل جزء لا يتجزأ
من استبداد الحكومة وهو أيضًا
لقد كان هدفًا متكررًا
لغضب المتظاهرين
جيدًا ، يمكنك سماع تلك الهتافات الساخرة
وما الذي يشعر به الناس
جيدًا بسبب نقص الخدمات الأساسية التي
لا تعمل الكهرباء معظم
اليوم
في قيمة الماشية من الليرة اللبنانية
تنهار بأكثر من
60 في المائة  كان هناك انهيار اقتصادي في
الوقت الذي
اتهمت فيه الطبقات
السياسية بالضغط على البلد ، حيث
يُنظر إلى الريحان في الشارع
كجزء رئيسي من ذلك ، لكن لديه أيضًا
نصيبه من المؤيدين وهو يقود
أكبر كتلة مسيحية
في البلاد في نظام السلطة الطائفي في لبنان.
هو أيضًا
حليف لحزب الله اللبناني المدعوم من إيران.
بعد
الانفجار الذي قمت
بتغريده وأنا أقتبس هنا حزن
الضحايا والدمار عظيم لكن
إرادة
الحياة أقوى من أولئك المسؤولين
عن الجريمة
بقصد أو إهمال ،
لذا يبدو أنك توحي بأنك
تعتقد
أنه قد يكون هناك  لقد كنت متعمدًا ما
تقترحه ،
شكرًا لاستقبالي أولاً ،
دعني أقول مقسمًا إلى جزأين أحدهما
هناك
إهمال مهما كان الأمر لأنه في غضون ست سنوات
توجد نترات الأمونيوم
بكميات ضخمة ،
لذا بغض النظر عن ماهية  شرح
هذا لا ينبغي أن يكون موجودًا
للجزء الأول
ولا يوجد مبرر لذلك
وأولئك المسؤولون عن
الإهمال
ليتم تقديمهم للعدالة الجزء الثاني
هو كيف حدث هذا لأننا نعلم
أنه لا يمكن اشتعاله
بدون  سيف آخر لذلك يمكن أن يكون هذا
إما
حادثًا حيث الحرارة
حيث كان هناك مفصل قابل للاشتعال نترات الأمونيوم
وكان هناك انفجار أو يمكن أن يكون  botage
أو هجوم ، لذلك لا ينبغي استبعاد أي شيء
ويجب أن تكون على دراية بالفحص من خلال
تحقيق شامل ، غرد
الرئيس والد زوجك
الرئيس ميشيل
أوين في الساعة الماضية مما يشير إلى
وجود احتمالين لما
حدث
إما أنه يقول إهمالًا أو
التدخل الخارجي بصاروخ أو
قنبلة تعتقد أنه سيدي
الثاني لا يمكن أن يفكر فيه أنه يجب علي
الالتزام بتحقيق تحقيق شفاف
ومستثمر وفعال ، ولكن في جميع
الحالات ،
كرر هناك إهمال
ويجب إدارياً وقضائياً.  أن تكون
مسئولة
عن أولئك الذين سمحوا وسمحوا
لمدة ست سنوات
بوجود
مثل هذه المواد الخطرة
والخطرة لفترة طويلة ، ومحكمة بيروت في
قلب المدينة ،
من المقبول على نطاق واسع أن حزب الله
له
تأثير كبير على الميناء
حيث
تم إخفاء قاعة ضخمة من نترات
الأمونيوم ومعظم الأشخاص
الذين تحدثنا معهم يجدون أنه من غير
المعقول أن  لم يكن هوريتس يعلمون
أن نترات الأمونيوم مخزنة في
ذلك
المستودع.
ثلاثة أيام
عرفوها وكانوا
كذلك لذا لا يمكن لأحد أن يتجاهل حقيقة
أن الوعي موجود الآن إذا
ثبت أن حزب الله متورط في هذا
بالطبع يجب أن يحاسب
إذا كان مسؤولاً بطريقة أو
بأخرى إذا أثبت التحقيق
هذا يجب أن
يأخذ نصيبه من المسؤولية وأن
يحاسب الآن نحن نتحدث عن
مدينة عاصمة لبنان التي
دمرت وقتل الناس
وجرحوا وهذا لا يمكن أن يكون
أه تعلمون عفوا
هذه فرصة للبنان أن
استعادة حالة أه القانون هذه
فرصة للبنان
ليثبت أنه على استعداد للتغيير
هذه فرصة
للقول أن العدالة فوق كل شيء لذا
هذه هي  ليس عملاً يمكن
تجاهله ،
حسنًا ، استمع مسؤولو الجمارك
مرارًا وتكرارًا وحذروا من الحاجة إلى التخلص
من هذه المادة شديدة الاشتعال ، فقد حدد تقرير
منفذ أمني
في أواخر عام 2019 على ما
يبدو مشاكل في المستودع
حيث تم احتجازه ، لقد عرضته عليك
مرة أخرى وكان لديك  اقترح أنه
إذا اعتبر حزب الله
مسؤولاً ، فيجب
محاسبته ، فهل تقبل
أنه من المقبول على نطاق واسع
أنه يسيطر
على الميناء ، لذا في هذه المرحلة ، فإن
أصابع اللوم
تشير إلى حزب الله ،
لا يجب علينا ألا نقبل
أن السلطات اللبنانية
حسنًا
تعلمون المجندون
والمرتبون مسؤولون ومختلفون
تعرفون العسكريين والمدنيين لدينا
العديد من المسؤولين الإداريين والحكوميين
المسؤولين عن ذلك من
الوزارات
إلى الجمارك إلى إدارة الميناء
أه إلى وحدات المخابرات أه
حتى هو وحتى القضاة
الذين تمت إحالتهم لاتخاذ قرارات
ثلاثة قضاة
تعلمون والمدعي العام
فلا س  لا ينبغي
استبعاد أي تحقيق ،
فمن مسؤولية
الدولة اللبنانية أولاً
تأمين الميناء الآن ما أشير إليه بشأن
حزب الله إذا كانوا مسؤولين عن
وجود المواد
أو التستر على وجودهم أو
استخدامها
أو عن وجودهم.  مسؤول بطريقة ما
عن هذا الحادث ، نعم يجب أن يتحملوا
هذا الجزء من المسؤولية
ولكن في نهاية المطاف
مسؤولية الدولة اللبنانية
التي كنت تمارسها في السياسة سيدي ، لقد
كنت في السياسة ، آسف دعني أوقفك
هناك
لقد كنت في  السياسة على مدى عقد من
الزمن كان
خلاله أه القضاء كان
قضاءًا مستقلاً تمامًا وقد
تم
هدمه بشكل فعال الآن أنت تقول
هذه فرصة
للإصلاح في هذه المرحلة
كنت في موقف
حيث كنت قد أشرفت بشكل فعال
كسياسي رفيع  زوال
القضاء المستقل ،
نعم ، أنت تعلم أن هناك حقيقة
وهناك تصور يمكنني فهمه على
حد سواء
يمكنني أن أخبرك بأننا  نحن نقاتل
نحن قوة من أجل
التغيير ، نحن نكافح من أجل التغيير ،
نحن ندفع ثمناً باهظاً في السياسة
لأننا نناضل من أجل هذا التغيير
ومن أجل
الإصلاحات ونعم علينا القيام بذلك في
القضاء الآن
يمكن أن تكون هذه الدراما الكبيرة  تحولت إلى فرصة كبيرة
لحل الأشياء لتغيير الأشياء ، نعم
علينا أن
نؤمن ببلدنا
وشعبنا وأنك تعلم أن فسادنا ليس
مصيرنا
علينا أن نؤمن بالتغيير الذي يجب
أن نكافح من أجله على الرغم من  كل
ما نواجهه وما نواجهه
تحت أه في بعض الأحيان لسوء التقدير ولكن
نعم ، لا يسمح لنا بعدم الاستمرار في
قتال
السيد بازيل أدعوك إلى عرضي
اليوم ليس لأنك
تمثل صوت الأغلبية.  من
اللبنانيين لأنك في الحقيقة
لا تجسد لملايين اللبنانيين
محسوبية الأقارب وفساد
النخبة الحاكمة التي أغرقت
هذا البلد في حفرة اليأس.
أكبر حزب
في البرلمان له تأثير كبير
داخل الحكومة مع الإشراف
على مدى العقد الماضي لمحفظة الطاقة
التي امتصت
ما يعادل نصف الدين الوطني
ومع ذلك لم يتم تشغيل السلطة
لمدة 20 ساعة في اليوم ،
أدعوكم لسؤالكم
عما إذا  ستتحمل
المسؤولية الشخصية والمهنية عن
أزمة اليوم
التي تعرفها في لبنان ، وعلينا أن
نفهم هذا النظام وكيف
يعمل ، فنحن أكبر
حزب أكبر مجموعة برلمانية ،
لكننا أقل بـ 20 من أعضاء البرلمان ،
لذا فنحن لا نفعل ذلك.  ليس لدينا الأغلبية في
البرلمان
ولا الحكومة وهذا هو السبب في
أننا نكافح من أجل أشياء لم
تتحقق ، لذلك بالطبع علينا أن
نتحمل رعايتنا
لعدم القدرة على التغيير ولكن ليس
نصيب المسؤولية عن
الفساد لأن  نحن
ضد الفساد نحن ضد
الفساد وندفع الثمن نحن ندفع
الثمن ولكن نحن دستور ديمقراطي
ونقبل  القاضي ، دعني
أتوقف ،
حسنًا ، أحد أركان الديمقراطية وقد
استخدمت للتو
كلمة المساءلة
إذا كان لبنان نظامًا ديمقراطيًا ،
يجب أن يُتوقع من الأشخاص في موقع السلطة
أن يحاسبوا
على ما يحدث ، أضعها لك  مرة أخرى
، هل أنت غير مستعد ولا يجب أن تكون هذه
الحكومة مستعدة
لتحمل المسؤولية عن هذا
الوضع المذهل الذي
تجده الدولة نفسها ، ليس
أقلها أن يكون الإهمال هو الذي
تسبب في هذا الانفجار ولكن من أجل
الانهيار الاقتصادي الكامل للبلد
تقبل حقيقة وجوب محاسبتك أنت وزملائك ،
فأنت تعلم أن كل شخص
أه في رد في مسؤولية عامة
يجب أن يكون دائمًا مستعدًا
للمساءلة ،
هذه حقيقة واقعة ولكن لا يجب أن يكون
مذنبًا بأشياء هو بريء
منها أو
بالعكس ، هذا سياسي ، أنا
ولا حزبي لدي أي مشاركة مباشرة
وحدثت واحدة ولا
مسؤولية مباشرة في الميناء أو أي شيء
متعلق بذلك
طيب.  ما زلنا نقول إننا
يجب
أن نتحمل مسؤوليتنا إذا لم
نتبع هذا الأمر حتى النهاية
حتى يكون الناس هم الأشخاص المسؤولون
وليس الأبرياء.